it was about 10 years into my teaching
career that I was thinking critically
about what is it my students are doing
and were they in fact doing science and
the realities they weren't they were
doing as I said canned labs they were
generating data that was predictable and
they weren't really having that
opportunity to fail at anything and then
have to do any error analysis whatsoever
and that's just not how science works so
over you know the past decade in
particular I've worked with other
teachers here and we started to look out
for broader scientific opportunities and
one of those opportunity brought in was
this Baba Kea project which involves a
lot of technical skill and a lot of
pieces and a lot of prep work you know
it's five days of lab and at the end of
that five days of lab it's not
guaranteed that you're going to get data
it's the antithesis of the labs that we
did before which we made sure we can fit
in a 47 minute period and we've get
known results at the end this is the
exact opposite